rihanna officially
becomes a billionaire
we got some rihanna fans out there in
the house today rihanna fans i love
rihanna i love rihanna okay not for the
music okay fair enough
um here's a forbes article forbes name's
rihanna the richest
female musician actually it's a usa
article as well rihanna shines bright
like a diamond
shines bright like a diamond okay not
bad not bad all right and as marcelo
says she is the perfect mix of hot
mysterious and talented absolutely can
we get th thumbs up out there if you're
a rihanna fan thumbs down if you could
care less about rihanna i'd like to see
what the crowd has said and regardless
of how you feel put some respect on it
jesse just became a billionaire you
understand with a k it's some respect on
that beyonce have a personal brand that
she's done like she has to like i mean
you would assume i mean we don't it's
not you know front page news anyways so
what we're learning here to wrap this up
yeah they're learning what what what can
these people take away from this
here's the deal the personal brand
is that new wave yeah right so the music
she's made a couple hundred million not
bad rihanna
but the majority of her 1.7 billion is
on this personal brand and it just
happens to be makeup so
um
working on a personal brand that's big
go ahead marcelo it's crazy that just
crazy to think that rihanna's skin has
made her more money than her voice like
she's given
she's given such an amazing talent you
know golden pipes but the way that she
looks has really made people go crazy
and then i agree she's made a billion
dollars if you enjoyed that short clip
from the size cast click here to watch
another click here to watch the full
episode or just stay broke
[Music]